hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with Andrew Malcolm
live from Freedom Fest in Las Vegas
Andrew thanks for talking to us great
debate investor's business daily what's
the URL for investors investors com /
Andrew Malcolm mal CE o LM you are a
veteran journalist you've done it all
you've been a foreign correspondent a
national correspondent you were laura
bush's press secretary for a while you
thrived in the online world when you
were at the LA times before you joined
investors business to LA you were this
breakup blogger for them you're great on
Twitter as well how do you do it why did
you do it and so many other veteran
journalists just seem to hate anything
having to do with blogging or online or
yeah they do you know when I got into
journalism which is back in the era of
hot tight I mean I got I went to the
University and starting in nineteen
sixty to journalism school I really
wanted to be a foreign correspondent and
I did that but the reason I went into
journalism was I wanted to learn
something new every day so along came
the online world I had seen my son who
is a webmaster and I had seen the
excitement that he had and done some
work online but not a whole I mean I
would write for print and it would go
online and so I would get readers that
way but so I was intrigued they
rediscovered my political background on
the LA Times and they asked me to invent
this conservative log to their credit
and they back me up one hundred and
twenty percent so why are so many kind
of stars of the legacy media world just
like a foot we don't need them that's a
that's an excellent question and if you
could answer it you could probably
determine much of the future of what
we've been calling legacy journalism I
suspect one of the reasons I got a lot
of antipathy when I got well I got
successful but when I got excited about
online because I was sort of preaching
it in a newsroom and I don't think they
were excited about learning something
new every day I think
were comfortable knowing what they know
and doing it very well and they liked
knowing that at three o'clock they were
in the same meeting every day I didn't
you wrote a blog at the LA Times that
had a lot of you didn't hide your
ideology or your interest in things that
investors dot-com you're still writing
where you you kind of do close readings
and deconstructions of official
narratives whether it's from the White
House or from the Romney campaign and
what not do you think online journalism
or new media favors one ideology over
another or is it a kind of value neutral
too well the two is an excellent
question the difference it seems to me
is that online media responds to the mus
customers okay traditional media has
been like the pharmacists behind a
counter every day we lined up they were
in their white coats they knew what they
were doing they handed out their
prescription news for the day we took it
and read it now we can make our own
choices out in the parking lot just 100
alternatives that we could pick from and
so the ones that get the readers are
successful the ones that don't aren't
that's not always been the case with
newspapers do you worry that I mean is
that a race to the bottom though is that
the lowest common denominator for
offline no no I don't think so it's what
the customers want to read my stuff
isn't frivolous but we do have fun and
if you want to know how politics works
from the inside then you come to read
mine because I've been a journalist and
I've been in politics if you want to
understand the intricacies of the health
care policy you probably don't come to
me but you'll have an alternative
somewhere else you don't have to wait
for the newspaper that decide to assign
a reporter to deconstruct the health
care bill a lot of people worry about
the kind of state of affairs of
mainstream media large large
journalistic enterprises like the LA
Times so do i do you worry that the
resources that they're able to bring to
bear two stories you know long-term and
long-form investigative pieces is that
going to go away or is that
you know in a world of online journalism
or customer center journalism I hope not
because so much of the world you and I
we were act to stuff that comes out of
these major news organizations every day
we live off of it if you drive to work
you don't realize it but ninety percent
of what you hear on the radio has come
right out of that morning's newspaper so
it they are crucial in terms of
generating news generally unbiased but
yes they have a slant ok and then others
chew on it and reach you it and so on
and that presents the alternative for
consumers they have I'm worried that it
they have to find a financial formula to
enable them to make more money online
and they're trying obviously paywalls I
hope somebody figures it out but in the
meantime it's a very difficult
transition period and these major news
organizations have had the shrink very
difficult when I went to the LA Times
there were something like 1200
journalists I think there's something
like 600 now but it's much broader news
organization now we're do partnerships
with ktla-tv there they've got a little
studio in the newsroom there they're
doing online now much more aggressive
they write things specifically for
online whereas before it was just what
the newspaper had so they are making
adjustments but it's very painful it's
very expensive this news generating you
know you want to send somebody over seas
to us do a story you're talking to a
million dollars and that's a lot of
money if the movies aren't advertising
with you so much anymore okay thank you
very much Andrew Malcolm of investors
business daily I'm Nick Gillespie for
reason TV
you